these fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say here what if
we try to build a generative adversarial
Network for 3d data this means that this
network would work not on the usual
two-dimensional images but instead on
three-dimensional shapes so the
generator network generates a bunch of
different three-dimensional shapes and
the basic question for the discriminator
network would be are these 3d shapes
real or synthetic the main use case of
this technique can be and now watch
closely taking a photograph from a piece
of furniture and automatically getting a
digital 3d model of it now it is clear
for both of us that this is still a
coarse low resolution model but it is
incredible to see how a machine can get
a rudimentary understanding of 3d
geometry in the presence of occlusions
lighting and different camera angles
that's a stunning milestone indeed it
also supports interpolation between two
shapes which means that we consider the
presumably empty space between the
shapes as a continuum and imagine new
shapes of our closer to either one or
the other
we can do this kind of interpolation for
instance between two chair models but
the exciting thing is that no one said
it has to be two objects of the same
class so we can go even crazier and
interpolate between a car and a boat
since the technique works on a low
dimensional representation of these
shapes we can also perform this crazy
algebraic operations between them that
follow some sort of intuition we can add
two chairs together or subtract
different kinds of tables from each
other absolute madness and one of the
most remarkable things about the paper
is that the learning took place on a
very limited amount of data not more
than 25 training examples per class 1
class we can imagine is one object type
such as chairs tables or cars the
authors made the force code and the
pre-trained network available on their
website the link is in the video
description make sure to have a look I
am so happy to see breakthroughs like
the
in machine learning research one after
another in quick succession this work is
surely going to spark a lot of follow-up
papers and we'll soon find ourselves
getting extremely high-quality 3d model
from photographs also imagine combining
this with a 3d printer you take a
photograph of something run this
algorithm on it and then print a copy of
that furniture and appliance for
yourself we are living amazing times
indeed thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]